okay we are live again for another of
the dr. Stadler
AMA sessions I'm just going to adjust
the lighting a little bit here and we've
got questions already lined up so I'm
going to jump into those without any
further ado let me post my usual thing
about patreon those who support me on
patreon thanks for doing so this is
that's what makes this sort of thing
possible for me so let's look at the how
many questions one two three four five
six we already have six questions lined
up so let's get started with those Harry
Doble do I know much about the post
modernism of Umberto Eco he says I was
wondering if you could talk about that
for a bit
so yeah post modernism is one of those
terms we got to be a bit careful with
there's not one post-modernism out there
there's a variety of them and actually
one of the better books discussing that
is although it's pretty dense as
Jamison's post-modernism
so EKKO himself was critical of some of
the other people that get lumped under
post-modernism like say Derrida for
example and you can you can see that in
his post modernism and the philosophy of
language but you know the real meat of
echoes stuff is is really in like his
theory of semiotics and these other
works primarily focused on developing a
comprehensive semiotic s-- and you could
ask a questions okay so so a semiotic
s-- postmodern and it really depends on
well whose semiotic sar you talking
about and what do you have in mind by
postmodern echo is is perfectly willing
to recognize some things that I suppose
you could say our our postmodern themes
you know very broadly like
a lot of people say that well here if
you're thinking that that language and
and signs play a central role and
constituting the reality that we're in
and that you could never get away from
those and so there's no like you know
absolute meaningful world out there that
you can connect with independently of
language then your postmodernist if
that's the case then a lot of people are
post modernists it and many of them are
actually there you know in early
modernity but yeah so you could call
echo I guess a moderate post modernist
if you if you want to say he doesn't
think that everything is up for grabs or
that you know some of the themes that we
see identified with it now today are
necessarily holding and he does seem to
think that there is you know things that
are better and worse objectively
speaking he just said think some things
are much more complicated than many of
the modernist would would say they are
and I think he's completely right in
that respect as a matter of fact echo is
one of the people who I do actually
recommend when people start asking me
about hey I want to do philosophy of
language or I'm interested in signs or
stuff like that because he's a very
accessible thinker all right Bogdan have
you read all Tuesday and if so what's
your opinion on him overrated I have
read him back in graduate school I
thought it was overly complicated and
much of it seemed to be the sort of
stuff that would date very quickly I
think that many of the people who talk
just like with a lot of thinkers I think
a lot of people who talk about you know
drawing on all to zaire don't actually
understand what they're reading I say
that too with like Hegel or you know
many many other thinkers as well people
are always advocating for certain things
and you're like well okay so what did
you get out of this book and they give
you the humma-nah humma-nah humma-nah
you know Kevin
hi sort of thing I think that you know
the stuff that's good and I'll to zero
you could probably get from summaries I
just don't it's not he's not somebody
who I see in the maybe thirty forty
years remaining to me and reinvesting
time to to study here's an interesting
one from Carl bod why do you think Plato
insists on giving us third fourth and
even fifth hand accounts some sort of
libel protection and more
epistemological reason also are you
going to George Webb's to get free
burgers although I'm not going to George
webs because it's gonna be mobbed
alright to get free burgers although I
do like George webs
that's a Milwaukee thing so because our
local baseball team is doing
extraordinarily well George Webb's has
this this offer you could call it almost
like Milwaukee patriotism right they
will they will give people free burgers
for you know celebrating the the Brewers
doing well and I think those sort of
things are great I just don't like
crowds so and I hate waiting in line so
no I won't be there now why does Plato
give us these these third fourth fifth
hand accounts fifth hand account I think
the only do we actually have a genuinely
fifth hand account maybe in the
symposium right because we have a story
that's being told that was previously
related of the speeches that were given
Socrates himself is recounting in the
heart of the dialogue
what do Thomas said to him so that might
be fourth hand that might be fifth hand
but we do have quite a few accounts
where you know think about the
theaetetus or other dialogues where
there's some framing going on
why does Plato do that it does he insist
on it he doesn't insist on and he's just
giving you these accounts and you can
read them or not reach them they're
there what we have and is it to protect
him from libel no not at all
that that sort of thing was
an issue back then in that way it could
be that that you know there's a couple
different theories out there about this
it could be that he's he's distancing
himself in some way from the doctrines
that are being put forth it could be
that he's inviting us into a narrative
framework which which is you know an
interesting literary device and I think
quite successful there might be other
reasons for it nobody really knows why
why he did that maybe he's trying to
give us some sort of demonstration about
his own abilities that's what you know
somebody like Nietzsche would probably
say or it could be that he's just
suggesting to us that any narrative is
by it by its very nature somewhat
unreliable and requires us to think all
right I am there now how often do you
reread philosophical texts do you reread
the entire text or just certain sections
depends on the text
I mean people ask me those sorts of
questions all the time like you know
I've been getting quite a few recently
on the doctors say on their bookshelf
tour or people are like how much time do
you spend on each book anyway how the
hell would I know I don't keep track of
that to begin with and you know some
books require more time some books
require less time it really depends on
on the work and how often do I reread
philosophical texts it depends on how
much time I have on my hands and whether
I'm teaching them and you know whether
I'm trying to do some work on them or
I'm reading them for my own edification
and do I reread the entire text or just
certain sections again totally depends
on the context I mean some texts say I
try to make a practice of rereading once
a year like going through des cartes
meditations in the French and Latin and
the objections and replies or Plato's
dialogues but you know for the most part
it's it's totally dependent on the
situation now here's an interesting one
from TK if you could mash together the
brains of two philosophers which ones
would you combine for the best results
and which ones for the worst results
worst results I don't know I mean just
pick any of the people who
kind of third-rate and probably disagree
with each other so there'd be a bit of
you know split personality there and
mash them together you know this is
actually kind of an interesting thought
because what happens in great
philosophers who actually work in a
dialectical manner and take up other
philosophers ideas and I don't mean the
bastardized thing that people call
Hegelian dialectic with the thesis
antithesis synthesis [ __ ] which is
not real Hegel anyway I mean I mean
dialectical and in Aristotle and
Cicero's sense the the ancient sense
where you're actually engaging with with
previous thought on a topic canvassing
at trying to incorporate what's best in
it and this is what you see thinkers
like Aristotle doing quite frequently
and you see that continuing on through
history you know with people who are our
brilliant thinkers on their own even
even the ones who pretend to be like
totally breaking from everybody else
like the carter hobbes aren't doing that
so in a way when we're doing good
philosophy we're already mashing the
brains of two or three or multiple
philosophers together and then calling
things out from them all right
Bertrand asks are you familiar with
Michelle Renee Barnes and his work no
also have you read much of st. Gregory
of nYSSA's work yeah but a long time ago
it's been it's been quite some time
since I've gone back to him I
there was some project where I was I was
using some of his ideas for something
was having to do with some history of an
issue but I don't even remember what it
was
so all right let me skip down here the
greeter what do I make of phthalates
first principle did he choose water
because everything needs water do you
think everything is made up of water
well he had a couple different reasons
why he
I thought water made sense I suppose one
thing would be you know seeing that it
takes different forms right so that
naturally suggests that as something
that could be other things and then some
of it had to do with like notions about
you know fossils of fish in different
places so he's thinking there was there
more water than there was before and
what do I make of the first principle I
mean you know obviously everything isn't
made of water
Nietzsche talks about this in his
discussion of ancient Greek thought I
forget exactly the title but was stuff
that was called from his classes he says
well this is important because not
because he picked water but because he
picked something yes the explanatory
principle for everything that made it
philosophical in a way that previous
accounts like you know mythological
accounts did not so that's you know
there's something to that I don't think
you'd want to stick with with always
thought I superior apparently was a
pretty brilliant guy he you know we tell
this in in philosophy classes to prove
that philosophers are not entirely and
practically managed to corner the olive
market
well the Olive Press market because he
was interested in meteorological
phenomena and he figured out that there
was going to be a great crop of olives
so he went around and rented all the
presses and then he charged people a
good bit of money to to use them and
made a fortune all right varam Andy I'll
alert could I explain the basic theses
or thesis of critical theory
well critical theory doesn't just mean
one thing so again we have an ambiguity
problem just like with post-modernism so
if we're being very strict about it in
terms of philosophy we should associate
critical theory with the Frankfurt
School Horkheimer Dore no
Marc who's a later on hawk grimace Apple
people like that erich fromm and fit in
there as well if we're using critical
theory in a broader sense like they do
and in live
classes it can mean anything you like
just about and so that's that's why I
don't usually use that term very much
unless I'm talking with with
philosophers so the Frankfurt School
they were Marxists and they they were
very interested in and troubled by the
fact that a lot of the predictions about
class solidarity and class consciousness
that should have in in the classic view
led to World War one being stopped
rather early by a number of proletarian
revolts and you know strikes and
cut-offs like that were in effect
co-opted by nationalism and so they
applied themselves to trying to figure
out all right well what the hell went
wrong why didn't things go as predicted
and in order to do that they wanted to
harness the resources that non Marxist
philosophy could bring to bear and you
might say social theory and psychology
so they drew upon all other sources like
for example Nietzsche or Freud and you
know in the case of Habra Moss all sorts
of other things later on but the idea
you could say what is what is it about
why is it called critical theory because
it's engaged in critique of culture and
ideology and trying to steer humanity
towards some sort of better position
some sort of better society being aware
as well of the fact that's simply
theorizing the world in a new way is not
automatically going to change it and
being quite suspicious of many of the
things that are put forward as
progressive as being genuinely so so I
you know that's that's a
characterization that could work for
that there's another one from speedix
what do I think about goat free to
vilhelm live Nets his work and his
personality do you know what he's doing
etc personal things
oh I like liven it's quite a lot I
actually you know my early work I was
doing a lot of stuff online that's I
haven't done anything for a while and I
haven't taught him for a while actually
but his discourse on metaphysics used to
be something I was reading and rereading
over and over again in part because I
really enjoyed it it's a very short work
but there's a lot of cool stuff sort of
encapsulated there live notes you know
it gets called the universal genius of
Europe and he really was I mean he made
contributions across the board from
history which was actually his day job
he was supposed to be the historian for
the House of Hanover and never quite
finished some of the projects to
mechanics to diplomacy to full you know
straight-up metaphysics and philosophy
and ethics to theological discussions -
was was involved in all of those sorts
of things so you know I think he's
somebody who's definitely worth worth
reading Giovanni
Lavanya wouldn't dare a tad more
accurately be classified as
post-structuralist
I guess so I mean post-structuralist
doesn't really mean that much either you
know it's you can't be a
post-structuralist without also being a
structuralist I mean reads speech and
phenomena for one you know for one thing
and you know it's same thing with a
postmodernist you know if you're a
postmodernist you're also a modernist in
many ways that's part of what the
original post modernists like leotard
you know disgust you can't just sort of
have these nice neat breaks and
classifications I mean I I'm much more
I'm much less interested in how do we
classify people and I'm much more
interested in let's get into their
thought and see what ideas are there and
which of them are [ __ ] that just
happened to be popular at the time and
people like because they sounded sexy
and which of them make a real
contribution to understanding things and
then where where are their connections
between them so yeah Daniel Cox to what
extent do you think any of the attempts
to
metaphysics like John Milbank or Adriene
papst after the critical projects of the
20th century example Heidegger Derrida
are successful well I mean you're
talking there about two radical
orthodoxy types and III think that
that's an interesting project but it's
you know it's not particularly appealing
across the board to many people I think
that metaphysics doesn't need to be
recovered you know I think that in
academic philosophy there's an awful lot
of faddish nests and an awful lot of
very bracketed thinking so I'm going to
give you an example of something that's
similar to like you know metaphysics in
terms of a revival virtue ethics right
oh you know 20 20th century revival of
virtue ethics starting with you know
these people like each and Anscombe and
all that that's [ __ ] complete
[ __ ]
virtue ethics never went away if you
read across the history of philosophy
there's just as much virtue ethics being
discussed in the early 20th century you
just got to look for it in places other
than Cambridge or Oxford right it's it's
not like it ever went away and so you
have this this sort of you know he used
another analogy here it's sort of like
they're living in a place that at one
time was fashionable and then went out
of fashion and then although they you
know yuppies and the hipsters come in
and they're like oh look at this this is
old brand-new and you're like where the
hell have you people been you know we've
been doing this living like this for
years and years and years so the same
thing with metaphysics I mean just
because Heidegger said you know we're at
the end of metaphysics or you know lucic
Derrida and the deconstruction of
metaphysics or jean-luc Mario you know
crossing out being and all that just
because those people say that that's
what's going on and be and just because
they have a big echo machine in lots of
people in in the Anglo sphere you know
who think those are sexy themes jumping
on that
it means that that's really the case I
mean people continue to do metaphysics
and there's always a metaphysics behind
whatever you know anti metaphysics you
put out you know this is one thing that
we're Heidegger was completely right
about Nietzsche right each has a
metaphysician he's also an antimatter
physician and I don't understand why
people are always so like thrown for a
loop by this sort of thing you know so
you know Milbank and and and perhaps you
know very I would say the same thing
with Graham ward or Catherine Pickstock
perhaps less so with Philip blonde you
know very sophisticated thinkers and
they're trying to you know draw on
pre-modern thought in order to you know
recover some sort of metaphysical
perspective and that's fine but guess
what plenty of other people were doing
that a long time before them including
some of the people like you know Milbank
idolizes blown del well blown del
actually did it better and more
thoroughly you know and and it's not
just the early blow now but throughout
his career and so did
Antonin sir th and so did Eve Simone and
so did and we can go on and on and on
with this mock Schaller was doing that
too you know in the phenomenological
approach and there were plenty of you
know
followers in the in the sense that
they're succeeding after Heidegger who
didn't think that metaphysics is
completely to be thrown away like gotta
myrrh or Arendt you know or paul ricoeur
right and we can go on and on and on
with this sort of thing so the question
that you have to ask is is it worth the
time to actually delve into these people
or should we just you know go back to
some of the classic thinkers Andrea
propriate them I mean if I was given the
choice between Milbank or a rent I'm
gonna read a rent you know I certainly
find her stuff more more interesting
[Music]
awful philosophy you should ask this
question right at the start
are there any terms that are thrown
about that just make you groan like for
me it's usually labeling everything bad
as postmodern yeah so I mean most people
who use the term postmodern should
probably not use the term because they
don't have any idea what the hell it
means
same thing for you know here's another
term that I think you know is really
worn out when I hear somebody accused
another person of virtue signaling I
just stopped paying attention because
there's nothing more virtue signaling
than accusing another person of virtue
signaling and people do that on the left
and the right it's not just a rightist
term people were using that term in
academics on the left before it became a
big thing on the right but it's a me it
just makes people sound so stupid when
they say stuff like that you know and
and they might not be stupid people but
they're choosing something that at least
for me is a huge turnoff yeah you know
post-modernism by itself is just bad no
or accusing modernism of being
automatically bad no that's that's
that's equally foolish Hegelian
dialectic whenever i have somebody who
tries to you know saw me as if I haven't
been reading Hegel for decades that
Hegel was really about thesis antithesis
synthesis you know I don't roll my eyes
but I'm mentally doing that so there's
quite a few things like that yeah I mean
I might come up with some some other
ones if some of it is kind of
time-dependent like for a while
everybody was reading levy nos and then
we'd all have to talk about the face of
the other and you know I like loving us
but after a while you get kind of sick
of hearing how we were facing the face
of the other right and and there's
there's stuff like that over and over
again there's these buzzwords in
philosophy that could get thrown around
you know another one from analytic
philosophy des feeders this is a
defeater again I hear that and and right
or wrong my mind just kind of like
closes not but I'm like this person
isn't worth listening to because of the
jargon you know all right Jay - Nick
favorite church father door Augustine
doesn't count
well I mean
I don't know that Augustine would be my
favorite anyway I like him and he's very
interesting and we certainly have a lot
of text by him that are worth reading
including some of the minor texts like I
like his stuff on I'm lying he's got a
couple pieces on that specifically but I
don't know if I had to pick my absolute
favorite among the people that are
called the fathers I guess if you were
gonna go by like my reading history it'd
probably be John Cassian or Clement of
Alexandria you know both of them I'm a
real fan of Clement I really like in for
two things in particular one is his
notion that the way in which human
beings are made in the image of God is
in that we are musical and the other is
his willingness to view ancient Greek
philosophy as sort of the Greek
equivalent of the the you know Jewish
Scriptures that the Christians call the
the Old Testament working for them I
like that sort of approach to things all
right Daniel Cox do you think there's a
meaningful connection between
Nietzsche's search for an over man and a
just hints of a possible return to
Christ after we reject Paul's corruption
of Christianity well I think the the
Paul you know Christianity things been
kind of done to death I don't think
things are quite so simple as well you
had the Gospels and then you had Paul
and Paul corrupted everything the way
they like to talk about in the
nineteenth century people like Renaud
and all that who Nietzsche had read you
know I don't think there's enough
material there to really get anything
out of Nietzsche himself with a return
to Christ I mean do you know what
Nietzsche talks most positively about is
actually the church as a political
institution you know he's kind of
admiring of their their ability to you
know harness and use power all right so
I don't think there's there's you can
get that much out of Nietzsche himself
but you can take you know people like
say ma Schaller and who's a Christian
thinker and
you know some of the other Christian
appropriations of Nietzsche and maybe
get something out of it
I don't know that like the death of God
theology stuff is is particularly
meaningful anymore that stuff has not
aged particularly well oh that's the
stuff from the 60s and the 70s like
Thomas holitzer
you know so yeah all right let's see so
here's a question that I get asked quite
a bit by syphon to shepper what's my
opinions on Schopenhauer I noticed you
do not have videos dedicated to them so
you should never draw any conclusions
from what I've got videos dedicated to
about how I think about somebody I don't
have any videos dedicated to Leibniz and
I just mentioned earlier that I really
like Leibniz what I actually am able to
shoot videos on is a function of time
and energy and quite frankly finances
you know the the more financial freedom
that I enjoy through patreon support the
more videos I'll be able to shoot and
you know I do Commission to videos as
well you know people are can you do a
video on this so I shoot him the video
that I shot where I'm like hey you want
a video on X commissioned me to do it
because this is the world we live in you
know there's only so much of these
resources so I like show up in our you
know said this many times I think he's
somebody who is not you know just to
read because you can't understand
Nietzsche without him I think that's
[ __ ] but you show up an hour's worth
reading in his own right he's an
interesting guy he's got a lot of great
stuff to say you don't necessarily have
to agree with his entire world
perspective to to really appreciate what
what it is that he is doing and I was
fortunate enough that I never got to
take a Schopenhauer class as a graduate
student but a couple of years back when
I was a visiting scholar at European
graduate school I was able to take a
Schopenhauer class with Wolfgang
Schirrmacher the at that time president
of the International Schopenhauer
society and
you know he talked about the white
schopenhauer as opposed to the gray
Schopenhauer you know and had a very
interesting interpretation of how we
might get a more optimistic Schopenhauer
who's the guy who has been reading and
teaching Schopenhauer for nearly all of
his career so you know there's something
to be taken seriously there I think
about that
so yeah the stroke now is great I don't
know when I'll shoot videos on and right
now I'm this this semester I'm shooting
videos primarily on the texts and
thinkers that I'm teaching in class and
so you know but if there's enough demand
you know I'll do it but it takes you
know takes some time and effort all
right here's another from Daniel Cox you
stressed the importance of primary
sources you don't seem to spend much
time with secondary sources does this
make it difficult to publish no not
really I mean I were like like I said
when I'm you know doing academic writing
I read secondary sources because that's
sort of the expectation and sometimes
there's interesting things that people
have to say in those I mean all you have
to do is you know you can go to
academia.edu and look at some of the
stuff I've published and you'll see that
that I do engage with secondary sources
but when I'm you know trying to think
about doing videos on Plato I'm not
gonna bother reading other people's
stuff I'm gonna read the Plato or you
know if I'm doing blog entries unless
there's something really compelling
about somebody's interpretation in which
case usually I'm reading them as a
primary source who's discussing Plato
you know like if I'm again let's take a
rent a rent has a lot of great stuff to
say about pry racists in the life of the
mind or maybe it's the human know it's
the life of the mind not the human
condition
well she's interesting she's not just
commenting on epictetus and Aristotle
she's developing her own thing so she's
in some respect a secondary source but
she's a primary source and then you know
when it comes to other
things like if I'm writing on pry
raceless I'm gonna see what other people
have had to say about it in the last 50
years but I know I don't use secondary
sources as my Avenue into a thinker you
know all right Mike ray how would you
describe your general political views if
you're comfortable saying that is well I
don't fit into the political spectrum
very well and you know whether it's the
right left spectrum or even if you want
to add a thorat aryan and libertarian I
don't fit in very well in part because
I'm a virtue ethicist and this is an
issue that goes all the way back to
classic virtue ethicists like Aristotle
and Cicero you're not going to find a
comfortable place because political
parties by their very nature as
coalition parties tend to attract people
who use the language of virtue butter
but are you know corrupt and out for
their own constituency and don't really
care much about the common good and
there are many people within political
parties who who do espouse that but they
don't rise to the top it's pretty rare
you know so you you pick the point often
the least of evils and for me that
they're frequently it changes from
election to election I can tell you that
this time around because the Republicans
have been so asinine on so many topics
including the whole gun control thing
and the NRA I'm going to do my little
bit of punishing them at the polls by
voting for their opposition which is the
Democrats but that's not really an
endorsement of the Democratic Party
which has all sorts of failures and
problems of its own and if the
Republicans get their act together and
start acting like decent human beings on
a whole bunch of different topics then I
might start listening to them again you
know other times they built third party
I usually do vote there have been a few
cases where due to like poor planning a
heaven--the but yeah and and I tend to
think that if you are this is something
that I'm in complete agreement with
Alister McIntyre
if you are going to be involved
politically it probably has to be at a
local level where people haven't become
quite so corrupted by the rising process
but even then it's you you have to
evaluate almost everything on a
case-by-case basis
so that's you know it's part of my
political views I'll say on a few topics
you know I think that our our system
that we have is very dysfunctional I
don't see any any easy ways to fix it
because unfortunately the people who
would fix it are benefiting from the
dysfunction and that would be the two
main parties and all of their lobbyists
and associated industries and the the
masses of people who love you know
thinking in a very blind 'red way and
consume the media sources associated
with them on both left and right but but
right now much more on the right so you
know for a long time I'd say it was more
opposed to the left now I'm probably
more opposed to the right there are some
things where as an American I think that
we are engaged in things that that at
this point we should have gotten past we
should have universal health care that's
that's you know that's not socialism
which is a dirty word for Americans
pretty much all the first world
countries do there's no reason why we
shouldn't have it we blow a lot of money
on military budgets and on policing and
surveillance and things like that and I
think you know a lot of that money could
be much better spent in social welfare
programs which I am for I think that we
should consider
you know how the lower classes are
affected by policies in in our
policymaking and you know I'm not for
like increasing dependency or anything
like that but I think that that's that's
much more of a consideration than how
some million millionaires are doing and
I think that we're also stuck there's a
here's a bigger picture political thing
I think that neither of our political
parties is doing
anything to rethink what we're going to
do in an economy we're probably going to
have thirty to forty percent
unemployment or underemployment as
robotics logistics AI becomes even more
prevalent and I think we ought to be
doing a lot of thinking about that
because this this idea of what we're
just going to create jobs is asinine
it's not based in any sort of reality
and we need to be thinking about how
we're going to keep society from
breaking down due to this and it is
there's going to be some sort of you
know top-down system whether cutthroat
capitalism or totalitarianism where the
the people who own the the the new means
of production are gonna super benefit
the rest of us are going to be
scrambling or screwed that's not what I
want to see and if a party actually does
decide that they want to do something
about that
I would love to see them engaging with
it but right now neither party is you
know all I also think that the climate
change is real and we ought to be doing
something about it and we ought to like
you know you know quit this stupid big
back-and-forth bickering about it that
doesn't serve anyone definitely not you
know the present environment or the
generations yet to come I think it's
extremely short-sighted of nearly
everybody in our Republican Party and
many of the people in our Democrat Party
not to be you know taking this seriously
and to be deluding themselves that it
that you know it's somehow just cyclical
or or something like that so you know
these are some of my political views I
have many more I suppose I could share
but those are the ones that are kind of
top of mine but you can see that you
know not going to make me very popular
with with either side all right let's
see what we got here
here's one from Horace Akbar was Thomas
More's utopia satirical work what are
the arguments for against this
interpretation it's been a while since
I've looked at it but satirical yes it
is satirical in in some respects right
is it designed to be you so you can ask
about like parts
and then you can ask about that the the
totality of it is the entirety of it
designed to be a satirical work I don't
think so but parts of it are targeting
you know things either existing in his
own time or at other times yeah so that
you know it depends on what you mean by
satirical so are we talking about
satirical in having elements of satire
or is the whole thing just supposed to
be a farce the way that some of say
Swift's pieces all right so good
question there let me get back to stuff
here Giovanna thoughts on origin not
somebody I've thought about for quite a
while so I haven't really thought much
about origin for a while gum nom your
views on David Bentley Hart again
somebody I don't read much of I'll say
that I appreciate that as a you know as
an an some scholar that he has a good
piece saying the Orthodox
interpretations of Anselm are pretty
off-base because they they are it's one
of those weird points of contention
stupid contention where there's like a
given story and then it keeps people
from actually like reading the text well
all right Jay to Nick what are your
thoughts on universals do you buy into
the forms theory how do we make sense of
particulars and universals in my
personal eclectic opinion I don't have
any problem believing that there are
universals do I believe in plato's forms
no because it's it's a very difficult
theory when you actually like use the
Platonic texts to make a hell of a lot
of sense out of it you know what's the
form of courage for example you know but
you know I guess you could say that I in
in some respects I'm I'm somewhat
playtest right I'm willing to believe
that that some some things are existing
besides just particular x' it's not
something I actually worry very much
about quite
frankly though rowboats thoughts on
Jacque Martin and dietrich von
Hildebrand I'm a fan of both I think
that Mara tan was sometimes over-hasty
and the positions that he took and a
little bit too rigid you know like for
example in my work on the Christian
philosophy debates I've shown that that
blown Dells position and the merit
Angela saw him position are actually
complementary to each other and that
they shouldn't have been at loggerheads
but that Martin and Blondell had bad
blood going way way back because Mara 10
was again over-hasty a member of axial
France says the proto-fascist hard right
Catholic organization run by an atheist
charmer ah
who Marit and stayed with until they
were condemned by the Vatican but I
think there's some some good stuff in
martin von Hildebrand I like quite a bit
you know for those who don't know who he
is he was a student of mock Schaller
he's got some really great works and
there's some really nice
phenomenological analyses of effectivity
and you know what the human person is
like on Hillenbrand of course influenced
other later phenomenologist like you
know John Paul the seconds Carole voltea
right who is is quite interesting as
well
so tiresome is a question here that's
not going to be easy to answer what does
Hegel mean by concrete Universal so the
concrete universal I mean this is gonna
be a very thumbnail sketch is where
within the historical development so
within some sort of context you have
something that really has the force of a
universal but it also exists as such and
and this is you know part of the
Hegelian dialectic in terms of ideas the
real dialectic not the thesis antithesis
synthesis nonsense actually it's not
nonsense I mean it does have some limits
scope particularly in Hegel's lectures
but in one of the things that you see
within Hegel's you know treatments of
things is ideas have to be made real
they cannot simply exist as ideas if
they're going to have some sort of
efficacy they have to be made veer click
they have to be made actual you know
you're often gets a lot of grief for
saying that the you know the rationale
is real the real is rational it's really
the real should be rational the rational
should be real how do we do this
how did it how did it happen in the
historical phases before that so the
concrete universal plays an important
role in in that and you can also think
of it as involving a certain kind of
subjectivity and agency figuring out
what it is over time Lukesh any opinion
on Valerie just scroll down here Valerie
somebody's boy there's a lot of
questions here Hardcastle's argument
that there's no such thing as
psychogenic pain nope because I haven't
read it and I don't even know who
Valerie Hardcastle is and I'm not quite
sure what's meant by psychogenic pain so
no no opinion on that
Tony hoof thing is in this age of
tribalism and division is there a
philosopher who would be informative for
us
lots again hon Arendt
all right a great person to read you
know again one of those books I was
mentioning earlier where people are
buying it but I don't believe that most
people are actually reading it because
it's so dense or rents you know origins
of totalitarianism book I think 90% of
the people who talk about it and only
read smidgens of it but great great
thinker who else I mean if you can read
them read hobb Ramos he's pretty tense -
Alistair MacIntyre
important thinker as well and we could
go on and on and on you know there's
there's plenty of people doing great
work ostensibly in ancient or medieval
philosophy but but you know thinking
things through like Julia on us you know
Chris guild has a great book out
recently on the structured self and
Hellenistic thought but that's things
that could make us think about the
present so there are like you know
hundreds of philosophers who we could be
looking at for understanding our current
condition Giorgio Agamben another
another you know good person in the in
the present all right aesthetics what is
ontology it depends on who you ask
right because different people have
different meanings some some it's just
identical with metaphysics you know
study of what is to anthos right to own
toes for others it's it's a more
restricted operation and you can talk
about it as like a field you could talk
about persons ontology 'he's right
Travis is Descartes himself a
hermeneutic interpreting a radical
foundationalism separate from the
philosophies of the medieval era and
antiquity that wouldn't make him a
hermeneutic person but he is engaged in
interpretation that he still uses ideas
from medieval and ancient philosophy to
make sense of things and then
reinterprets them sure which
philosophers great one from hench Pinner
which philosophers should an economist
read well you should read the people
that the original when political economy
emerged from philosophy you should read
those those people themselves and read
the people that are precursors to them
that they're responding to I mean
Aristotle has has you know important
economic discussions in say politics
book one right he there's there's a
pseudo Aristotelian text the the
economics which is worth reading to and
so you could read all those those those
previous discussions of that
um and and read it not just to like see
what they had to say but to think about
do these contribute any useful models
for us how we think about value people
in the present who are incorporating or
critical of the economics you probably
should read them as well alright okay
here's here's a good one chip if you
could have one dead philosopher come
back and comment on the work of a
specific one of their predecessors who
would you pick
[Music]
man that is a tough one so what we want
is somebody who really understands one
of their predecessors well and putting
aside the language issue because you
know like if you know let's say Cicero
showed up I wouldn't be able to speak
Latin yeah or Eagles showed up you know
my German is not good enough to be able
to follow somebody explaining high-level
concepts to me yeah so now I guess I'd
pick somebody who I'd really want to
talk to myself and I guess you know if I
if I had to to pick somebody who I'd
most like to talk to it'd be st. Anselm
and who would I have him comment on
maybe Augustine maybe Boethius maybe
John Cassian so yeah probably not the a
choice that a lot of people would relate
to philosopher ed you said your mother
had books like how to make your child
exceptional is how to give your child an
exceptional mind looking back on it what
about your childhood environment their
parenting encourage your intellectualism
so I mean I was I was fortunate in that
I had good you know good
gifts to begin right I am somebody who
could do a lot of abstract reasoning
quite early and I was very curious and I
was I was already like you know as a kid
like arranging things into patterns and
stuff like that right but my childhood
so my I was fortunate that my mother
could stay home a good bit of the time
she actually did when I was when I was
young and my dad was still in law school
at uw-madison she did work at the Oscar
Mayer Factory part-time which meant we
ate a lot of you know Oscar Mayer
baloney and hot dogs and things like
that but she was very devoted to the
idea of of helping me to develop my
talents and I don't know exactly what
she did I don't remember most of this
but I know that I was reading by the
time that I was three and then you know
I started reading my way through the
world book and you're just consuming
whatever was was put in front of me I do
remember my dad actually at one point
telling me to knock off you know reading
street signs because I was doing that
almost obsessively as we were driving
around and it was distracting him and my
dad spent a lot of time you know talking
with me and doing things even though he
was a very busy man you know he had a
CPA and a law degree by the time that I
was 3 he became a tax attorney and we
you know we ended up moving around a
little bit within Wisconsin before we
finally settled in he started teaching
me mathematics when I was 4 and he had a
calculator that he used as sort of like
the thing to get me to start paying
attention to that and they'd let me
check my work right I also had people
within my my family my larger family the
la Maria's side of the family who were
were cultivating me my great uncle
Hubert
only had you know I think a sixth grade
education but was one of the best read
persons that I I've ever met
he read continuously very much in favor
of culture would buy us books and
magazine subscriptions as presence and
wanted to know what you were reading and
what you got out of it and he practiced
this himself he wrote notebook after
notebook of entries of what he thought
about this book or this movie and there
were other people like that within the
family as well many of whom didn't have
much formal education but who applied
themselves and I know that I you know
when I was a kid I went to a Montessori
preschool when I was four that probably
did some good you know and then I went
to you know public kindergarten and
elementary school so that was that was
good and then on my father's side and
here I'm talking about me of course my
adopted parents my grandmother was you
know she was intellectually oriented as
well and so I think all of that played
an important role in in how I developed
but much of it was like letting me do
things letting me go to the library and
get books and read things and study on
my own and encouraging me to do so not
you know and I saw my parents reading
and that is probably a very important
thing too I saw people taking pleasure
in engaging in thinking and conversation
and reading so I was very fortunate
because I would say many children who
are adopted that's not always the case
right so good for them
alright here's a question from Travis
care to elaborate on des cartes
hyperbolic doubt its prevailing
influence and how philosophy moved on
from it
well you know it's it's hyperbolic or
methodological doubt it's you know
provoke discussions for years and years
and years about whether you could do it
whether it's a good thing to do some of
which are on track some of which are not
you know all the way down to like per
saying you can't really doubt like then
whistles saying yeah you need to do
something like that once in your life in
his Cartesian
patience what do I need to elaborate on
well you know it's very thorough going
doubt but Descartes himself is using it
as a tool every semester you know you
teach the meditation and you always get
like one student who doesn't read past
meditation too and like is worried that
everything's a dream from now on and and
that's not where did cart ends up right
these and notice to that Descartes
himself says that this sort of doubt is
not for everybody there's some people
who would never make their way out of it
and other people who it just doesn't
doesn't suit
how did philosophy move on from it you
know you don't have to be a Cartesian
right there's other ways of doing things
I think a lot of the moving on from it
didn't take the carts doubt that
seriously but you know you can say that
about many other things as well I
suppose right all right let me see if I
can get back now to the previous
questions oh here's another one - from
condo Tierra which philosophers take up
the topic of loneliness or solitude in
their works well Epictetus has a whole
chapter on loneliness or solitude in the
discourses so that's a good one to check
out and of course Seneca in his letters
on consolation to different people talks
about that as well the sort of the
subjective feeling of loneliness I mean
you could check out Cicero's Tusculum
disputations which is about the Stoics
wells about not just the stoic theory of
the motion that's books three and four
but also death and things like that
you know I suppose you could say that
boethius's consolation of philosophy
kind of is touching on that in the early
parts - and then somebody who's not
often considered a philosopher but I
would say is worth calling him one is
Rainer Maria Rilke and he talks about
Ines M kite which can be translated as
solitude or loneliness plays a major
role in his thought Pascal is kind of
touching on it too you know
mostly in terms of like the
transformation of physical perspectives
on the universe he says you know the
silence of these infinite spheres
frightens me or terrifies me
you know the fois is the the French
fills me with fear so there's there's
quite a few people and and you know in a
way Nietzsche is also another important
thinker to consider when it comes to
that because he's very often writing
about being on his own you know
let's walk with our Zarathustra is
filled with reflections on that so I
think that would be those would all be
good starting points all right ty ty
suru explain rationale is real real
rational I already did that bug Don
connive the sick are there any slavic
philosophers you find interesting
yeah I've mentioned left chest off many
times bear Jaya have I I enjoy as well I
mean who else particularly comes to mind
nobody you know nobody else really pops
to the top of the line for me okay
as foreign what are your thoughts on the
interpretation of the loses dialectic of
the servant to the mastery so this
dialectic is already written from a
servant point of view since the
postulate is you will need recognition
while the true master will not seek that
well I think Toulouse is doing what
Toulouse often does which is he's doing
his
philosophy but doing it from the losers
perspective which is often quite
interesting but you don't go to work
likely the faithful interpretation of
what you know what the the ideas are and
you know it where's Toulouse getting
this from I'd say in part from Nietzsche
right made of clay probably a vague
question do you feel like people who
dismiss post structuralism modernism or
say it's dangerous or right to do so as
in everything that it teaches is
completely wrong no I I think I think
that that people who say that any
philosophy is completely wrong don't
know what they're talking about and
probably should spend either shut up or
spend more time studying philosophy you
know so this is a little bit off topic
people feel like they have to have an
opinion on all these different things or
somehow they're like not intellectually
engaged you know it's fine to like step
back when it comes to post-modernism
just because people around you are like
condemning it doesn't mean you have to
do that I mean they may be totally
off-base the the the in you know the the
honest intellectual thing to do is to
find out for yourself read the stuff you
know and then then come to conclusions
about it and don't just like read it to
automatically find the the quick answer
read the stuff immerse yourself the self
in it and then see if it if it is still
bad or [ __ ] after that right same
thing goes for any philosopher you know
people are like oh yeah Nietzsche is
terrible or take Iran right Iran is just
all garbage right well reader I mean
then you'll be able to figure out what
parts are garbage and what parts are
actually on track I mean she uses the
notion of a hierarchy of values is it
somehow like you know just complete
ideological nonsense and Rand but
somehow in mock Schaller the notion of
hierarchy of values is a good idea mmm
you know nobody's completely off-base so
you know it's you don't have to feel
like like people are corralling you in
and you have
take a stand on this stuff it's it's
fine to like take a step back and say I
want to find out for myself you know
maybe you're right about this this stuff
being terrible or bad or corrosive maybe
you're wrong about that huh you know why
place such faith really just blind faith
in the interpretations of other people
when it comes to these matters all right
brewmaster what do you think is the
basis of knowledge which out of
foundationalism coherent ISM or infinite
ISM do you find most plausible or if not
any of these three may be a separate
theory well I don't do isms so if you
say foundationalism I'm gonna want to
know whose foundationalism which you
know foundation on what all right I
don't even know what infinite ISM means
and and coherent ISM could mean a lot of
different things so I think that you
know we don't have a basis of knowledge
I'm not sure why we think we need a
single basis of knowledge anyway and we
can't be more pluralistic about this and
recognize that our knowledge comes to us
through a number of different modes all
right I am now are there any good books
that explore the psychology of the
shortsightedness of most revolts you
know I don't know about that I can say
that there are you know works out there
that that discuss revolts that took
place and where they want off track and
and what didn't work and maybe what
would work in the future and how these
you know wonderful ideals that people
put forward are often co-opted or or
break down so that could you know that's
that's a possibility but you'd have to
dig around for those okay
the astronaut's XD what's the best
introductory book on symbolic logic I
don't know I mean we used kopi I'm
perfectly fine with kopi there's other
ones out there they all more or less
cover the same thing
some of them have a few little twists
and turns that they add to it but you
know it's it's more or less the same
stuff August I know you're covering
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit what do
you think of it compared to the science
of logic
I think the phenomenology is easier
that's the science of logic which I find
to be a Hegel's toughest work and
distinguish the science of logic from
the encyclopedia logic the encyclopedia
logic is much easier so yeah that's
probably good enough chip do you think
it's important for a society of a
particular Canon of literature and art
that all educated people study as part
of their education I think it's
important to have a wide cannon that
people select from I mean I I can't
think of any society ever that had a
cannon that all educated people within
that society ever studied and there and
then there's studying and then there's
like passing tests on right where I
think a lot of the the sort of like
looking back to the good old days people
in the good old days often just sort of
got through the curriculum I don't think
many of them actually understood it
particularly well but yeah I think it's
useful to have some sort of cannon but I
don't think we have to be slaves to it
so yeah there's my view Vadra
how would you describe the current state
of Western current state of current
Western culture it's it's a mess
terrible mess and there's more than
enough blame to throw around that no one
particular group should be accorded all
of it who should be so lucky is to get
all the blame right and we just you know
we keep plowing away and keep muddling
through I think that you know I think
we're we're gonna be down the line is
some some day
we're not going to speak of just Western
culture or wouldn't we do well speak of
it as sort of like you know Western
European / American and then we'll
contrast it or compare it with the other
things that we've we've brought in as
amalgams like Chinese culture Indian
culture and we'll we'll look at it as
you know we look at Western culture
somewhat anachronistically as being you
know Athens in Jerusalem or Athens
Jerusalem Rome and we're probably gonna
look at whatever culture survives us as
Western culture which is a mix of
different things along with lots of
other things as well and I view that as
a good thing because I you know I'm
interested in where humanity is going I
don't particularly care just for the
West's philosopher and how did you and
your wife get connected again after so
many years so yeah I think a lot of
people don't know this this story my my
wife and I met each other back in high
school I was a year ahead of her and
then you know we interacted for for a
while there but she was you know we
could have dated but it would probably
given our family situations terrible
mess but but you know we were involved
with with other people and things like
that and then we ran across each other
just about four blocks from here in in
Milwaukee in the 1990s we worked in the
same massive office building I was
working as a third shift security guard
she was working in a bank and we would
cross paths and flirt with each other
not knowing that we were the same people
and then much later on we reconnected
through social media through through
Facebook through a mutual friend at that
time of ours who was at one time my my
arch rival but who had become friends
with and then we began writing to each
other and fell in love with each other
through you could say a purely
epistolary relationship
before we started speaking on the phone
and then finally met face to face for
the first time in that would have been
so the 1995 to 2000 something quite
quite a while and then we did the
long-distance thing for for a while and
then that I moved up to New York and so
yeah someday we may actually like write
this down it didn't make a good
screenplay I don't know if that'll
happen so moving on
gingka berry to to petunia muffin named
dr. Sadler is freewill an illusion maybe
yours is - and no free will is not not
an illusion it's probably not what what
people make it out to be like this total
freedom of a difference or something
like that and there are many things that
conditioned us but we do have some
freedom we're a little bit over time I'm
going to take as many questions as I can
spedex what do you think about
supernaturalism occultism witchcraft etc
does it exist and also about secret sex
Illuminati Satanism masonry and how
they're described in philosophy and
you're against it well I think these are
not all the same thing supernaturalism
can mean multiple things but one thing
it can mean is there is something beyond
just the realm of observable nature and
that doesn't necessarily tie you in with
occultism
or witchcraft or anything like that as a
matter of fact a good portion of the
history of philosophy would be super
supernatural in that sense right you
could think of Plato's forums as being
form of supernaturalism secret sects you
know I mean there again get a look at it
on a case-by-case basis I think that
there have been plenty of secret
societies some of them you know quite
powerful some of them quite pathetic and
everything in between how they're
described in philosophy philosophy
doesn't spend a lot of time describing
that that sort of stuff
so I think
plenty of popular culture stuff and
literature that that does but there's
not a hell of a lot of discussion of
that in in philosophy all right
[Music]
Kostas do you think Hegel was against
intuition and if not how do you think he
actually incorporated this notion into
his philosophical system again we're
dealing with a lot of equivocal and
ambiguous words intuition means a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people
if you mean like sort of like gut
reaction or something like that that's
something in place at the level of gufu
feeling and it's sort of the the poorest
type of knowledge that we have purely
subjective you know every once in a
while somebody will be right but they
can also be right by using their brains
using the intellect you know doing
beyond just mere gut impulses or
something like that
hi sir please explain Hegel's preface
against preface --is any commenting on
the fact that you know if you're doing
some sort of systematic work it's
difficult to summarize it which is what
you're supposed to do in a preface you
know and and a lot of people back at
that time and at this time just read the
introductions and then skim over the
body and read the conclusion of works
and Hegel is commenting on how that
that's not a very good approach to die
electrical philosophy then he's
providing you with a lot of the tools
that he's gonna use and ideas in the
work so I don't think that's very I mean
read any any sort of introduction of
Hegel and they'll tell you about that
all right all right I'm gonna skip over
some of these other Hegel things and the
virtue ethics joke native clay have you
read any john d caputo how do you feel
about him you know
caputo is a good second-rate philosopher
you know he's a commentator on Derrida
and and other people I don't find him
particularly interesting and I you know
I've actually you know
then at conferences where he's
presenting and you know he's got a
shtick and you know what it is and and
I've met many of his students and they
all have their same SCANA stick and you
know they can do what they want to do it
doesn't doesn't concern me much I've
already answered the question that
Deutsch rap asked do you have a
political standpoint or do you engage in
politics some way a little bit earlier
well out-of-step Nate reminds me I do
have a video dedicated aliveness and
whether he's in Descartes shadow yeah I
forgot about that
that was from when I was first shooting
stuff and it was still at Fayetteville
State University I'd shoot in the
classroom and I did these dr. Sandler
chalk and talk lectures and the track
and track thing was to stick it to the
educational experts who are always
saying no you can't do truck and talk
can't do lecture anymore was a sort of
very faddish notion in in curriculum
design in the mid 2000s onward there's
still people saying that sort of
nonsense today that the lecture is dead
a good example again by the way right
virtue ethics is is coming back
metaphysics is coming back they never
disappeared the lecture is coming back
it never disappeared it's always a
question of whether people are doing it
well or doing it poorly you know and
just you know spending some time to
figure out where people are are doing
that disciple of rah Hegel's writings on
Christianity worth delving into it was
Hegel's conception of God how does this
interpretation differ from Orthodox
theology so you mean like the early
Hegel stuff right when he was still
working with shelling yeah it's worth
reading there's an entire section of the
phenomenology that's entitled religion
so you know and Hegel actually had a set
of lectures that he did several times
lectures on the philosophy of religion
so are they worth delving into
definitely yeah I mean it depends on do
you want to know what Hegel's views were
on these things yes they're they're very
important Hegel thinks that religion is
sort of like philosophy almost
philosophy you know
the less developed people it's in the
realm of forced along or you know
representation as opposed to conceptual
thinking the cave but it's an important
part of our development and you can't
really understand history without
understanding religions not buying into
them but understanding them and so Hegel
thought of you know his view is that God
is actually ultimately the human
community so you could see that you know
feuerbach is in some respects being the
more faithful reinterpret of Hegel when
it comes to religion and they're
endorsing a kind of humanism I am now
I've ever read Peter W zap I don't even
know that person's name so no or if I
have you know maybe wrote in some
anthology that I read years and years
ago but that that I don't I don't know
chardee macdennis what is Kierkegaard
mean and he says by virtue of the
absurdity mentions it frequent in fear
and trembling I've never got the concept
of it
so Abraham acts by virtue of the absurd
that is he engages himself in what he's
doing in the sort of you might say
inability to explain it to other people
in a rational way and the anxiety that
provokes but he the absurd means that
there's like a whole set of open
possibilities as well so that's that's
probably the best way to look at it I
mean you know you could read left chefs
tossed Kierkegaard in the existential
philosophy oh it's great discussion by
somebody thought kicker God didn't go
far enough with the absurd and you know
you would get both Kierkegaard's notion
and chest on ocean there Bogdan are
there any Marxist intellectual as you
find interesting and if so who are they
not including Marx and Engels yeah I
mean there's like a whole history of
Marxist back and forth debate about you
know how should Marx's ideas be
mented I mentioned earlier talking about
the critical theory and the Frankfurt
School those guys are Marxist I think
they're interesting I have friends who
are our Marxists and and you know we
engage with discussing these these
matters I'm not I'm not a Marxist myself
but I'm not an anti Marxist either I
think Marx has a lot of interesting
points to make and that you know the
focus on economic basis is important and
it's you know play in ideology and I
think you know there are classes hey
they're more complicated than Marx
described because we're living in a
different time but you know yeah all
right can seven do I have videos on
analytic philosophy not at this time
I'm a down the line depending on you
know if I find the time and if people
Commission me to do them the one thing
that I would probably do is is you know
eventually I'm gonna start putting
together curricula that I wanted to do
for a while on the Indian civil service
exam helping people prepare for that and
their history of philosophy segment has
some analytic philosophy in it so you
know there's that let me scroll down a
bit Thomas what is a gap year a year
that you take off and you do something
instead of study like I did or I worked
first in a gas station and convenience
store then came down here worked in a
mortgage company for three weeks till
they folded and then got the security
job saved up some money studied my
languages read exercised and if I hadn't
done that I could not have gone to
graduate school cuz I was so burnt out
on school by that time hi sir what is
the distinction between the left two
galleons and right galleons so the right
of galleons were more conservative and
they thought that essentially what we
need to do is just make you know reality
the reality that we live in more
rational but that Hegel had essentially
laid out the blue
for that the left two galleons thought
that the Hegelian sort of let's call it
techniques and tools were not fully
exploited and and we needed to do more
so they were the ones you know wanting
to carry out some sort of revolution
allsey rani what do you think of those
who say that Hegel and Marxism is just a
rebrand
Lutheranism I think that's completely
wrong and I don't know why anyone who
actually understands Hegel or Marx or
Lutheran theology would say anything
like that but yeah
varam and Andy O'Leary are you familiar
with Noam Chomsky's thought what are
your thoughts on them as I've mentioned
this many times as a linguist I you know
I was very interested in philosophy of
language so as a linguist
Chomsky's interesting I don't think he's
right about you know these basic
structures and you know he's an interest
when it comes to politics
he's a very consistent leftist thought
you know thinker so he's worth having in
the conversation and gotta admire
consistency right so let's see here
I'm not sure how to read the Cyrillic
things here so I'm just gonna say maybe
Sawa I've never heard you say anything
on CS purse maybe I'm mistaken
yeah I've talked about him here and
there before I mean where I went to
graduate school was was a pluralistic
Department analytic continental and
classical American philosophy so of
course I you know read a lot of Perce
James Dewey and I read some Royce and
Emerson and people like that as well and
you know purse is important for semiotic
right again we started out this thing by
talking about Umberto Eco purse is one
of the great triatic semioticians
a lot of people like you know what Jakob
sin and Helms laugh and people like that
and then you've got the you know
semiology coming from this will sir when
you guys hear about you know
post-structuralism talking about the
disel sir and onward sort of ideas but
yeah I mean purse is okay he's
interesting it's worth reading I guess
if if we're Americans and beginners and
philosophy at the state of English
translations and English works do you
know any non English contemporary
philosophers that might not be
translated well contemporary you mean
like people who are alive today I don't
know you know I'm sure there's lots and
lots of stuff but I don't spend a lot of
time reading contemporary philosophy
anyway I'd say there's lots of 20th
century French and German an Italian and
Spanish you know language philosophy
that has not been translated as part of
why I did the translation that I did
yeah well you have to stay with English
translations and English works until you
learn some foreign languages do that and
a world opens up for you all right
so all right
Gustavo what would be your suggestion to
a guy starting his philosophy journey
and his reading Aristotle but wants to
jump to a modern philosopher but feels
overwhelmed by possible required reading
to get it well start with Descartes and
Hobbes then there's not a hell of a lot
of required reading in order to get into
them is there I don't think so
you're certainly gonna find reading
Descartes helpful for reading Spinoza or
live nuts
and if you feel like jumping from
Aristotle all the way into the modern
age then go ahead and do it you know I
mean part of the the philosophical
journey is like making mistakes in your
reading stuff you know and being like
holy crap I can't do this I guess I'll
have to backtrack and you know you you
find out what works for you in that
respect I didn't you the first time you
read stuff you're not gonna get even
like 30% of what's in it anyway you
to keep rereading and rereading and you
can always go back to the ancients I
mean I I don't even like I'd have to
like chart out who I read first at what
time you know but I'm sure it's just a
mess if I look at it and you know that
games later I can say that there's some
parts of the history of philosophy that
I know quite well it's just sort of a
gradual process I would say my
suggestion to a guy starting his
philosophy journey is don't expect too
much of yourself at any given point
right don't be too hard on yourself that
you have to like totally understand
Aristotle hell I don't totally
understand Aristotle there's there's
there's Aristotelian text that I haven't
read for years and years and years
that's okay you know there's there's
others that I'm an expert on and that's
that's how it works
Bob Johnson what is the best path for
living the best possible life well
figure out what your actual values and
priorities are then figure out whether
you've got those right and then start
implementing those all right Coast us I
think
Aristotle's more hard to understand
because the ambiguity of the notions he
presents and modern philosophers they
tend to be more precise and learn what
modern philosopher you're talking about
sometimes the precision is misleading -
all right so there's still a lot of
questions and we're getting close to
half hour 20 minutes over now okay
these John what are my views on neo
Hegelian analytic philosophy people like
Brandon and McDowell
I haven't read McDowell I read the read
Brandon Brandon is so he is an analytic
philosopher but the more that he does
where he's like delving effectively into
non analytic philosophers the less like
an analytic philosophy is and the more
like
a historian a philosophy he is so he's
got his origin and analytic philosophy
but I I would say that a lot of Brandon
stuff isn't really an alike philosophy
anymore so and that's a good thing quite
frankly somebody wrote that would be
awesome for a series on Thomas Reid well
yeah the common sense philosophy he's an
interesting guy but you know I don't
teach him very often and I mean just
when I teach like modern philosophy
when's the last time I thought that's
years so yeah all right in a balk have
you ever taken psychedelics I think it's
a fantastic tool for a philosopher
psychedelic influence on philosophy
there's almost no psychedelic influence
on philosophy there's plenty of like
conspiracy theories out there but
they're based on so much could be
possibly maybe this refers to this and
they're usually I'll just find spun
[ __ ]
have I ever taken psychedelics it
depends on what you account is that I
once I once got a dose of PCP that I
wasn't intending to get and never would
have and I tried ecstasy once but
neither of them are really psychedelics
I don't do acid or mushrooms or things
like that I think a lot of the the
notion of opening up you know doors it
would really depend on the preparation
of the person and drugs are a crutch you
know I mean the things that you can
accomplish with them you can probably
also accomplish in other ways through
visualization and meditation and most I
mean most of the people that I know that
that are really into psychedelics are
dummies and dots and and you know you
listen to him it's the same stick over
and over and over again there was a few
brilliant people I've met who were into
that but not but not many of them so I
think for a lot of people they would not
be helpful at all
I mean could could they be of some use
sure it's sort of the way that
antidepressants can be of some use but
then you got to work on your
once you've got that crutch in place to
produce any lasting effects and and I
think that the the notion of shortcuts
there are no shortcuts in philosophy
period you know you put in the work or
you don't you know all right let's see
AP have you read Mon ten yeah I like
montón he's an interesting guy there's a
funny question from Fabio
why is Hegel hard to read well because
he's dealing with very complicated and
intertangled concepts for one thing and
he's also not a great writer for another
thing right he's hard to read in the
English and he's hardly read into the
German and sometimes he like you know it
takes terms and makes them his own and
does new things with them so those are
all reasons why Hegel is hard to read
all right let's see here
so Frances asks what it can't mean by
the synthetic unity of that perception
the first critique and then somebody
writes there's like a million resources
on that it's quite true so even the
synthetic unity at perception we're
perceiving things and we don't perceive
them just as a bunch of like little bits
of data sort of like you don't think
about you seeing my face you're not just
seeing a bunch of pixels there is some
sort of synthesizing process that puts
things together and there are many many
resources on that what's my favorite
quote from Z sound I don't know I don't
have favorites comes to most things
anymore what a terrace hears from we
keep that we all we keeps it real boxing
what did Aristotle Manor he said a happy
person could never become miserable
that's a quote totally taken out of
context it's it's from you know if I
remember right probably Nikhil McKay an
ethics book one and he's discussing you
know conditions but you know happy
people can in fact become come unhappy
if not necessarily miserable for
Aristotle because happiness depends on a
couple different factors
all right to do static on monotone do
you consider yourself a philosopher or
someone who teaches philosophy both you
know I don't necessarily consider myself
a first-rate philosopher but you know
I'm definitely a philosopher I actually
describe myself when when people are
like well what do you do
I say I'm a philosopher in private
practice although this semester teaching
an awful lot so I'm almost yeah I'm more
than a full-time academic if you look at
the different places I've spread my
classes out over but yeah I'm a
philosopher to do anonymous why are
people trying to control the social
discussion for a while now the Democrat
and Republican Party has become more
extreme why do you think this is
happening is it because people are
fractioning lives into smaller groups so
that's a big question and there's a lot
of research out there on this sort of
stuff
but I think you know a good bit of it is
the sort of unwillingness to engage with
with other people and I think social
media has made this worse because you
can you can have echo chambers where
everybody's you know essentially blowing
smoke up your butt telling you how great
you are and how terrible those other
people are and it's how it's all their
fault that didn't help and I you know I
think there's very few people who
despite their lip service you know to a
common good or something like that who
actually do care about a common good or
give any thought to what that might look
like which would include a society in
which we can actually have genuine civil
disagreement with each other all right
let's see
at 11:30 or 1:30 let me take just one
more I'm not going to get to everybody
but that's usually the case so first
sure I've been reading Locke chapter 5
in the second treatise it seems that the
introduction money renders his measure
of property and the three provisos
was unaccounted for is that correct
renders his measure of property when
you're saying measure of property mean
like legitimate amountof and the three
provisos that there's like you know
enough left for other people that sort
of thing yeah I mean actually Locke
talks about the use of money as a
involving tacit and voluntary consent to
a new arrangement of things and money
money allows you know they labor to be
bought right and it allows new new ways
of organizing land and the economy and
property to occur so is so is the
introduction of money in rendering these
unaccounted for I don't know what
unaccounted for means in this case but
it certainly does transform things so
all right we're we're now quite late
usually I plant about an hour for this
I've got to get to grading and a number
of other activities before I meet with
my patreon supporters for the philosophy
chant later on today so thanks for all
of your questions and comments and yeah
there's quite a few like I said I didn't
get to but not too many at least this
time around so that's that's good all
right I hope all of you have a great
weekend and maybe I'll see you in
another one of these
these online events